ou encore chabrol on la connaît aussi
pour avoir chanté les textes des plus
grands comme gainsbourg
depuis quelques mois l'artiste dany fait
la promotion de son nouvel album horizon
doré et en attendant de pouvoir remonter
sur scène la chanteuse de 76 ans profite
de sa nouvelle vie à tour lucas chopin
la rencontre et c'est dans un parc
tourangeau que nous la retrouvons depuis
sept mois dany est de retour sur la
scène médiatique avec horizon doré un
nouvel album simple principalement
guitare voix et aux sonorités rock n
roll mais ce rock'n'roll pour la
chanteuse reste avant tout un état
d'esprit site une attitude qu'on adore
la vie par exemple pour moi la callas
est une femme très très rock donc et
elle a chanté l'opéra donc je le prends
comme ça
après le son qu'il ya dans un album bye
peut être europe oui si vous voulez mais
des fois mais un morceau juste au piano
voix c'est aussi sur l'album neuf
morceaux tantôt drôles ou mélancoliques
mais aussi un duo plutôt inattendu
questa questa interprété avec joey starr
didier c'est quelqu'un que je connais
depuis très très longtemps et c'est
quelqu'un qui est un poète pour moi et
surtout c'est un artiste brillantissime
bon et puis cette chanson lui plaisait
puis il a dit pourquoi on la fait pas
rendu au voilà on l'a fait ces rendez
vous de la vie
du doute à fond la caisse et redoutent
contenait
je voudrais partout ailleurs à la fois
thani figure historique des soirées
parisiennes dans les années soixante dix
coule aujourd'hui des jours paisibles à
tour proche de sa famille elle a trouvé
de plus un nom en touraine
un cadre de vie qu'il apaise j'adore ces
jardins ici je connais pas encore assez
parce que confinement je fais de la
promo confinement que ça mais je trouve
que le vieux quartier là bas c'est assez
sympa charme fou je sais pas je trouve
qu'il ya une espèce de sérénité et de la
jeunesse les étudiants la loire pour
autant daniela sûr elle ne connaît pas
le mot retraite dès que possible
l'artiste de 76 ans engagera une grande
tournée à travers la france
[Musique]
odeurs
j'appartiens